[Música]
y cerramos el viernes También hablando
de economía está conmigo en el estudio
Jorge Hurtado Jorge cuéntenos Cuáles
fueron las principales conclusiones y
reflexiones que dejó el foro económico
Mundial de la ciudad de davos en Suiza
Buenas noches buenas noches Santiago
bueno sin duda esta semana se debatió
muchísimo sobre todo de la guerra en
Ucrania el cambio climático y la amenaza
de una recesión mundial la conferencia
en Suiza reunió a 52 jefes de estado o
de gobierno 19 gobernador de banco
centrales del mundo y más de 600
directores ejecutivos en economía el
pesimismo reinó en davos y se transformó
en un leve optimismo ya que las
perspectivas de la economía mundial
mejoraron un poco respecto a lo esperado
en el encuentro se discutió sobre las
presiones de la inflación derivada de la
reapertura de China y también el
creciente endeudamiento de los países en
desarrollo y se lanzó una fuerte
advertencia de parte de la Organización
Mundial de comercio sobre el french
shoren un término usado para referirse a
los países que están fomentando cadenas
de suministro entre aliados políticos e
ideológicos a nivel comercial y del
mismo tiempo excluyendo a países como
Rusia y China escuchemos
Bueno dije hay dos cosas sobre el french
cuando dije Quién es un amigo Un amigo
hoy no estás muy seguro de que sea un
amigo mañana hemos visto ejemplos de
ello Así que tengamos cuidado en segundo
lugar si estamos pensando en crear
resiliencia saliendo con diferentes
amigos incluyamos también a los que
están en África sí por qué no quiero
decir los amigos no deben estar solo en
Asia están en América Latina están en
África hay países que pueden ser
perfectamente lugares donde concentrar
la fabricación los incorpores a la
cadena de suministro global y así
también los incluyes
Santiago las tres grandes potencias
comerciales Estados Unidos Europa y
China promovieron sus nuevas políticas
industriales pero no quedó claro si el
resto del mundo va a encajar en estas
nuevas políticas comerciales que están
redefiniendo ya las cadenas de
suministro también las instituciones
financieras que luchan Contra viento con
problemas como la inflación y nuevas
presiones de los reguladores para
aumentar los niveles de capital y así
prepararse para una desaceleración
económica tuvieron cierta participación
en este encuentro al tiempo que estas
instituciones financieras deben sumarse
a la avalancha que supone la transición
ecológica los bancos centrales también
se mostraron firmes en continuar
endureciendo la política monetaria para
bajar los precios una herencia de la
pandemia y sus efectos económicos
incluso muchos se enfrentan problemas
locales que suponen más presión a la ya
complejas economías emergentes como es
el caso de Perú que hemos abordado
durante esta semana escuchamos
no estamos esperando todavía una presión
de crecimiento un poco por debajo de
tres por ciento dos coma ocho dos coma
nueve que es una de las más altas en la
región de todas maneras y esperamos
llegar a inflación de 3% también a fin
de año no la inflación subyacente que la
que lo va a concentrales sino inflación
total inflación subyacente planteemos a
la meta el próximo año es dos más menos
uno algo más baja que Chile Colombia
resto de la región no Jorge como era de
esperarse la Guerra de Ucrania tuvo un
papel protagónico en este encuentro
allí en Suiza bueno la guerra y sobre
todo su impacto en la economía global
ahí compareció el presidente para pedir
fondos armas y otro tipo de ayuda para
su país la primera dama o Elena zelenzca
instó a los poderosos presentes centavos
aumentar su apoyo el canciller Alemán o
las Charles el único líder del g7 en
davos fue presionado para para enviar
tanques a Ucrania aunque no respondió de
inmediato fuera de occidente el temor de
una recesión económica puso de relieve
las divisiones mundiales con algunos
delegados que pedían volver a la mesa de
negociaciones escuchemos sí que decía la
primera dama de Ucrania
clima
espera el mundo alcanzar la neutralidad
climática si ni siquiera puede tener el
incendio de ciudades ucranianas enteras
Esto es lo que hace Rusia con su
artillería sus misiles sus drones
iraníes todos saben que la agresión rusa
nunca pretendió detenerse en las
fronteras ucranianas esta guerra puede
avanzar y desencadenar crisis más
amplias y Ucrania pierde
se trata de miles de niños a los que
tenemos que proteger para que no pierdan
el contacto con sus parientes y Su
patria qué es lo que hace Rusia al
entregar miles de niños en adopción
ilegal a familia rusas
Muchas gracias Jorge por esta
actualización a continuación en directo
a América una semana en el mundo
[Música]